>>> MAJOR SHAKEUP ON CAPITOL
HILL.
SENATOR KYRSTEN SINEMA TOLD CNN
IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW SHE IS
LEAVING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
REGISTERING AS AN INDEPENDENT,
THE SECOND TIME SHE HAS SWITCHED
PARTIES.
>> GREEN PARTY ACTIVIST TO
DEMOCRAT, TO 6 MODERATE, TO
CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRAT, TO
INDEPENDENT.
ARE YOU JUST GETTING MORE
CONSERVATIVE, OR ARE YOU IN
SEVEN OF A HOME?
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> SO MY VALUES HAVE NEVER
CHANGED.
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN THE PERSON
THAT I AM TODAY.
FRANKLY, I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO
MY PARENTS AND THE LIFE THAT I
HAVE HAD THAT HAS LED ME TO HEAR
WITH ALL THE EXPERIENCES I'VE
HAD TO LEARN.
BUT I TELL MY FOLKS THAT I PRIDE
MYSELF ON MY WILLINGNESS TO
LEARN AND GROW.
AND I KNOW IN THIS TOWN PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE IT IF YOU EVER GROW
OR CHANGE.
>> TOP SENATE DEMOCRAT CHUCK
SCHUMER AND THE WHITE HOUSE WITH
POINTING TO WAYS THEY HAVE
WORKED WITH SINEMA BEFORE IN A
BIPARTISAN FASHION.
BUT THE MOVE DOES CAUSE SOME
UNCERTAINTY IN HOW DEMOCRATS CAN
CONTROL THE SENATE GIVEN THEIR
INCREDIBLY SLIM MAJORITY.
I WANT TO WELCOME IN JAMES
CARRVILLE, S.E. CUPP.
JAMES, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF ALL
OF THIS WHEN YOU HEARD ABOUT IT?
IT WAS LIKE MANCHIN/SINEMA WAS
ALMOST ONE PERSON OVER THE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY.
SHE IS PULLING THE RUG OUT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> I AM A CLOSE FRIEND AND
SUPPORTER OF RUBEN GALLEGO IF HE
RUNS FROM 2024.
IF I WERE A KYRSTEN SINEMA'S
POLITICAL ADVISER, I WOULD
ADVISE HER TO DO JUST THIS.
SHE IS NOT GOING TO BECOME THE
UNITED STATES SENATOR COME
JANUARY 2025.
I LOOKED AT POLL NUMBERS FROM A
BLUE RIBBON OUTFIT.
FAVORABLE IS 5 FAVORABLE, 82
UNFAVORABLE.
AMONG INDEPENDENTS, 25/56.
YOU DON'T NEED 42 YEARS OF
POLITICAL EXPERIENCE TO SAY
THESE ARE NOT WINNING NUMBERS.
THE OTHER THING, IT'S JUST A
FALSE CHARACTERIZATION TO SAY
THIS CHANGES A WHOLE LOT.
THE ONLY CHANGE THAT IS
DISCERNIBLE IS IF A DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR IN A STATE WITH A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR DIES THAT
WOULD BE TO THE DEMOCRATS'S
DISADVANTAGE.
FURTHER MORE, I GIVE SENATOR
SINEMA SOME CREDIT.
SHE DID THIS AFTER THE GEORGIA
ELECTION.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO BE
RE-ELECTED.
SHE PROBABLY KNOWS THAT.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO WATCH, YOU
KNOW, 20 POLLS SHOWING HER 72
POINTS BEHIND IN A DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE AMOUNT.
IT IS REASONABLE IN HER
INTEREST.
>> SHE SAID SHE IS NOT CONCERNED
WITH THE CRITICISM.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN A TARGET OF THE
LEFT.
THAEURB GOING TO CALL YOU EVERY
NAME IN THE BOOK.
A TRAITOR, INGRATE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO SAY?
>> I THINK I WILL DO WHAT I
ALWAYS DO, JAKE, KEEP DOING THE
WORK THAT I KNOW IS IMPORTANT
FOR MY STATE.
YOU KNOW, I JUST -- I'M NOT
WORRIED ABOUT FOLKS WHO MAY NOT
LIKE THIS APPROACH.
>> S.E., MITCH McCONNELL HAS
PREVIOUSLY CALLED SINEMA THE
SINGLEMOST EFFECTIVE FIRST-TERM
SENATOR HE'S EVER SEEN.
OTHER REPUBLICANS ARE CHEERING
THIS ON.
THEY'RE KIND OF GIDDY ABOUT
THIS.
>> LISTEN, SHE CERTAINLY KNOWS
HOW TO BE THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION AND KEEP IT THAT WAY.
VOTERS BE DAMNED, TO JAMES'S
POINT.
SHE'S NOT POPULAR AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
SO THIS WAS A CANNY MOVE.
I DON'T PSYCHOLOGYIZE.
JUST KEEPING HER SEAT.
MAYBE SHE WANTS TO BE WOULDED
AND COURTED.
MAYBE SHE IS FEELING MORE LIKE
AN INDEPENDENT, WHICH IS FRANKLY
HOW A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL IN HER
STATE OF ARIZONA.
BUT THIS IS CERTAINLY A CANNY
MOVE TO REMAIN A CENTRAL FIGURE
IN THE SENATE, A CENTRAL FIGURE
IN ARIZONA EVEN AS SHE'S VERY
UNPOPULAR THERE AND SHE WANTS TO
KEEP HER JOB.
>> JAMES, THERE'S A LOT OF
INTERESTING STUFF GOING ON THESE
DAYS.
WE LEARNED LATE YESTERDAY THAT
KARI LAKE, THE REPUBLICAN WHO
LOST THE RACE FOR GOVERNOR, IS
SUING STATE ELECTION OFFICIALS
ASKING THE COURT TO DECLARE HER
A WINNER.
IS THIS LIFE AFTER TRUMP NOW,
ELECTION LOSERS DISPUTING THE
RESULTS?
>> ALL RIGHT.
KARI LAKE, SHE'S OUT THERE.
SHE'S GOOFY AND STUPID AND
IGNORANT.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT'S GOING ON
IN ARIZONA.
PROPOSITION 211, CITIZENS BALLOT
MEASURE TO TELL PEOPLE THAT
SPEND OVER $5,000 IN MONEY IN
ARIZONA THEY HAVE TO DISCLOSE.
THAT PASSED 73%.
ARIZONA HAD A BALLOT MEASURE TO
ALLOW NONCITIZENS TO PAY THE IN
STATE TUITION.
THAT'S BIG NEWS.
KARI LAKE BEING GOOFY,
RIGHT-WING, STUPID, IS HARDLY
BIG OR STARTLING NEWS.
I MEAN, SHE LOST.
SHE'S DONE.
BY THE WAY, NEW MEXICO, THERE
ARE THERE IS DAY CARE GOING ON.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT DON'T
INVOLVE KARI LAKE.
WE SHOULD BE VERY AWARE OF
THESE, JIM.
VERY AWARE.
SHE'LL KEEP DOING HE EVERY STUNT
SHE CAN PULL TO GET ATTENTION.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE BIG
STORY COMING OUT OF HERE.
>> YEAH.
S.E., WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
ONE THING TO CONTRAST HERE THAT
IS KIND OF NOTABLE WHEN TRUMP
WAS CHALLENGING THE ELECTION
RESULTS AND PEDDLING THE BIG
LIE, THERE WERE A FAIR AMOUNT OF
FOLKS ON THE MAGA SIDE TOTALLY
ON BOARD WITH IT.
CEARLEY LAKE IS ALMOST SHOUTING
INTO A VOID.
>> YEAH.
>>> AND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
FOLKS JUMPING ON THAT BAND WAG
ONTO THE OVERTURN ELECTION
RESULTS IN ARIZONA.
>> LOOK, TRUMP CHANGED A LOT.
10 YEARS AGO IF YOU HAD NOT ONE
BUT SEVERAL ELECTION LOSERS
SHOUTING ABOUT CHALLENGING THE
RESULTS AND REALLY JUST BEING
POOR SPORTS THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
LAUGHED AT.
TRUMP DOES IT AND IT WAS
NORMALIZED FOR A TIME.
HE GAVE PEOPLE PERMISSION TO DO
IT AND NOT BE EMBARRASSED BY IT.
IT'S BEEN SO INRECEIVINGIVE IN
THAT IT HAS OVERTURNED NO
ELECTIONS BUT IT HAS REALLY HURT
THE POWER AND THE IMAGE OF THE
PARTY.
FOR INDEPENDENTS, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, YOU'LL NEED IF YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR OFFICE,
IT'S A HUGE TURNOFF FOR THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND THE
NEVER-ENDING PHONY AUDITS AND
RECOUNTS AND LAWSUITS.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE SICK OF IT.
AND IT'S NOW